this is Hannah this is not Jesus Christ
I know it's very confusing it took me
years to get that correct hi I'm Mary
Calvi Jude under-19 is different now
it's the end of this month what must
this may be it's made those favorite
favorite things let's do it no
hesitation no reservations only
hesitations and the only good tradition
but not be a Food Network show I would
watch this is very tender and I would
love her yeah there's a fly on my
microphone it's the name of a podcast I
would not ever listen to yeah everybody
were you doing take a bug probably bop
and Josh what if that photo on the other
side of room which is all sex wings
everywhere you guys had no idea this
whole time yeah yep see ya you'll see
okay I'll see it is something I got sent
for free which is not the formula for me
automatically putting it in a favorites
video though this is what this is lamb
glow glow starter mega illuminating
moisturizer hydrant mega illuminant wow
I'm exhausted is reading all the ways
they describe their product this is what
I understand to be a tinted moisturizer
I put this on my face before I slap
other paints on my face and just create
layers and layers and layers of hiding
and it's really fine um feel good on my
face it doesn't feel heavy and it smells
so good I don't know how what does it
smell like I can't place what the smell
is but it smells really good it smells
like like um thank you
it sounds like you're doing your life
correctly it smells very
overcompensating Lea but not
aggressively overcompensating Lea decent
this is the kind of smell that I would
imagine like a girl that gets a full
night of sleep and wakes up and has a
very active day and gets a lot of
productivity done and also have a very
healthy relationship
I imagine that like her natural body
odor is this scent so that's why I like
this very much I'll let you know in like
a week's time if I get some sort of
scabies of the face because of it but so
far so good neck and I can't say yeah
yeah yeah yup ticket is my microphone ah
yeah
it is L'Oreal Paris infallible Pro glow
toy for our foundation more words more
words police thank you I have this
L'Oreal get wearisome I put this in
favorite videos before this is their
infallible Pro matte foundation that I
love very very much because it gives a
very matte finish to your face and I
like looking like a canvas that you buy
from Michael's craft store but this one
is their pro blow so it gives you a
little bit of a glow and it's a little
bit less opaque they put a little grid
on the back for helpful looking at
finish Demi matte natural radiant this
one's radiant oh you're welcome we're up
to 12 hours 16 hours 24 hours 24 hours I
don't know that's totally true
I usually end up having to reapply this
in a few hours but doesn't mean I don't
like it coverage low medium high medium
texture err light medium rich air light
I will say it this feels very light on
my face and when things sit on my face I
don't want them to be heavy sit with
that person next matías oh yeah yes yes
but yes the scent it smells nice it does
not smell bad I love a little bit in
James since I put them in favorites or
goes before I've talked about bourbon
which is a really great Center they have
and I've talked about Nirvana black
which is really great set and this is
their scent rose which came out when
they released bourbon and it's a little
bit to me more feminine you know I'm not
going to gender my sense what am I am
Eddie I just lean into this thing that
I'm best at which is describing scents
this smells like it smells like hot so
hot flowers hot pressed flowers if
you've got cake mix from a CVS and you
made a birthday cake and then you shove
flowers in the middle of it you let it
sit in the Sun for a couple hours not to
the point it would go bad it'd still be
edible it smell like this and I enjoy
that why they don't send me their
products for free I don't know because
obviously I up soda out of them yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh no these are geode you
know what geodes are well that's
embarrassing that you do or do not know
geode the rocks
that's a crystal inside is the actual
definition of gog Oh a small cavity in
rock lined with crystals or other
minerals
I and a slightly intoxicated state urges
numerous packages of geodes off of
Amazon for a very inexpensive cost and
they come with rocks and basically you
just burst them open and then you find
the crystal that's inside I can attest
to the fact that it is a very fun
activity that leaves you with a very
beautiful product at the end of it here
is me in action with a geode and I was
gonna break up the first time it was
aggressive beautiful that's worth it wow
that girls having a great time and is
very capable and responsible and
productive also follow me on Instagram
and you look beautiful and inside they
make great gifts and make great crafts
they make a great way to procrastinate
next yeah yes yeah seriously this is a
shirt that I recently purchased when I
was in New York City and I packed poorly
for my trip and all of my clothes are
very dirty and it needs to go to a
professional event and it had nothing to
wear so of course I scurried to the hmm
men's section and found this shirt which
I enjoyed very much and I've got nothing
but compliments on this shirt every time
I wear it you can see that because
people like it or because they are
confused as to why I'm wearing a men's
shirt obviously so they cover their very
obvious confusion faced with a verbal
compliment either way people are paying
attention and isn't that the goal
probably Vulcan technology the HM men's
section for any of you that are curious
right now has a lot of very tropical
themed prints and t-shirts and things
and set for any of you fellow short
torso errs out there that hmm well men's
clothing in general has a longer torso
than women's t-shirts and so they fit me
better oh hi guys exhausted being so
thorough in my review and so helpful in
my advice now if you think if you can't
see it but you can you can see that it's
available for pre-order chimeric book
memory just announced that she is
everything a second book that is
truly exciting to me because our first
book was so good I haven't read it yet
but I trusted it's very good memory
second book is all about not telling the
same story twice so she's been on a
billion trillion adventures in the last
year and is writing them on a book form
for you guys so I highly recommend
checking that out there's a link in
description box below to go pre-order
her book and oh that got so dark in here
I mean emotionally I got very light and
supportive but the lighting got so dark
anywhere there are my favorites for made
you guys enjoyed this video here two
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to this YouTube channel to make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes
what have you guys been favoriting leave
it in the comments below so definitely
absolutely read all of those comments
for sure I don't know it does not smell
bad which is a great review of anything
that's meant to be smelling good and to
increase your body's overall goodness of
smell maybe I am an AI robot and this is
the moment in which I find out about
that because that cave-ins was jittery
oh no my foundation with my impression
of a girl you never want to spend time
with